dont le procès qui oppose johnny depp on
board aux états unis tous les coups sont
permis mademoiselle hurd a fait des
allégations odieuse et dérangeante après
s'être accusés mutuellement sur leurs
excès de violence amber heard a attaqué
johnny depp sur son rôle de père en
l'accusant d'abord d'avoir fait fumer de
la marijuana à sa fille lily rose alors
qu'elle n'avait que 14 ans
déclarant juste que johnny depp l'aurait
laissé près quand tu es un homme bien
plus vieux qu'elle à cette époque ingrid
est ce giorno
manipulation qui aurait totalement
dévasté la jeune femme et qui aurait
poussé vanessa paradis sa mère à la
prendre quelques jours chez elle à paris
par ailleurs vanessa paradis aurait
refusé de témoigner dans ce procès pour
préserver sa fille heureusement que l'on
peut toujours compter sur nos mamans
[Applaudissements]
vanessa paradis n'est pas témoigner pour
protéger sa fille qui voit là c'est très
bien pour les enfants moi je vous le dit
dans l'avion lors d'un divorce pour leur
vécu quand même pas trois fois on va pas
se mentir non mais on rigole mais préfet
qui témoignent ses propositions ceux qui
racontent n'importe quoi ce qu'ils font
des faux témoignages maintenant ils sont
toujours bien compris et c'est très
compliqué c'est très compliqué mais là
moi je trouve extrêmement élégant de la
part de man et sa part a dit parce que
la veille quand même 14 ans avec lui ça
a été un très bel amour elle le protège
aussi elle a reconnu parce qu'elle a été
obligée de déposer aussi qu'elle n'avait
jamais connu de violence n'a jamais été
violent ni à son égard ni à l'égard de
deux enfants qu'ils ont ensemble donc je
crois qu'on peut la croire ibid avant
maintenant dans ce procès c'est très
compliqué c'est toujours pareil parole
contre parole et puis en pleine période
mitu c'est un peu compliqué mais cela
dit aux états unis ça se retourne contre
amber heard on sait qui est plutôt
étonnant parce que du coup on la croit
plus elle a raconté tellement de salades
qu'on la croit plus parce qu'alors il
faut rappeler qu'en amérique dans les
procès quand vous qu'on traite on prouve
que vous avez menti même si ce n'est pas
en rapport avec le pjd anton marne c'est
assez préjudiciable
et c'est condamnable quand ça peut vous
mettre à fait en défaut a complètement
complètement et là il est en train de
perdre un béret en même temps elle
appelle fais caca sur l'oreiller de son
mari c'est dingue france pour qui messi
comment tu peux penser d'aller d'aller
déféqué sur un oreiller pour avancer sur
sa demande
ne va pas de georges et les pas du tout
pas du tout ces personnes je demande
c'est d'être
bon c'est quand même qu'on en vient à
parler du caca dedans mais qui font ce
qu'ils veulent en fait un débat super g
n'est ce procès par tout ce qu'on entend
mais je trouve que c'est un déballage
qui à gerber a chance on regarde et on
allait débattre du kkk ouais c'est
vraiment débat c'est à dire ouais
non mais t'es pas une gauche
à l'ewi cdc défatiguer tous les deux en
fait le résultat est là c'est qu'ils
sont fatigués et que vous êtes fatigués
sauf s'il est fatigué on voit bien
qu'ils sont pas faciles sont pas finis
maintenant
on était comme des l'autre c'est
dramatique parce que au final la petite
elle se retrouve exposé comme ça dans un
divorce qui est en plus leur histoire à
tous les deux ça regarde pas la petite
quoi je veux dire faut pas la mettre au
milieu et sa mère est la raison de la
prendre et de la protéger parce que
c'est un drame qu'est ce qu'on fait au
final ça fait quoi ça fait des articles
min dans le lit avec qu'est ce qu'elle a
demandé et pas de réception père est là
mais c'est vrai que nous on regarde
cette histoire avec du recul comme un
divertissement mort sont pas cons de la
fonctionnelle des enquêtes fiscales
internationales oui même pas de pire non
plus à s'être semble y g de regarder est
ce que le ce qui se passera en procès
parce que tout et tu vois ton père qui
considérait comme un alcoolo et même
quand même et violent tu ne peux pas
t'empêcher de regarder le procès a
demandé à ces firmes la mentalité
française quand on voit la réaction de
vanessa paradis et l'attitude des deux
autres américains là et ben bravo à la
française des jeux du coup la pauvre
lily rhodes elle a dû interrompre un
tournage en soi mais tellement elle a
mal pris la mal vécu cette histoire
c'est sordide e mails et effectivement
les enfants ni quoi que vous nous en
silencieux parce que je sais que ça vous
touche ces histoires de séparation et
d'enfants chez leur maman mais je sais
c'est vrai mais non mais en l'occurrence
le fond du procès c'est entre deux
adultes est ce que fait en ce moment ce
qu'elle fait c'est très simple c'est
qu'elle est en train d'essayer de décret
limite maximum oui mais ça ne fonctionne
pas alors là sur l'histoire aux états
unis sur l'histoire du haschich ça peut
effet bien sûr ternir son image et ça
peut même leur envers les aînés jadis
psychologiquement les jetons que ça
c'est dangereux quelle femme est
distillé de la vérité et du mensonge
surtout que là il s'agit de vérité qui
l'a jamais un enfant de 14 ans et si
c'est le cas et je pense
qu'effectivement ça a peut-être pu
arriver mais à la rigueur ça ne regarde
personne et ça ne regarde pas les juges
puisque le problème du procès c'est
entre un couple qui se sépare et entendu
il fallait pas rendre ils se sont pas
les mets conjointe de m'aider car c'en
est terrible c'est ça si je pense que
l'image de johnny depp est ternie
heiarii black bean games est le problème
je rejoins totalement ce que dit nicolas
le problème c'est que dans la campagne
de décrédibilisation de nombreux bugs ce
sens mail tellement les pinceaux elle
obligée d'aller vraiment gratter pour
avoir des vrais éléments des éléments de
ce qui se sont réellement passé parce
qu'elle est un nouveau rebondissement
elle a testé qu'un jour elle a eu peur
que sa soeur ne soit poussée dans les
escaliers tel qu'il l'avait fait à kate
moss il ya plusieurs années kate moss
avait déjà témoigné en faveur de johnny
depp les juges ne voulait pas prendre en
compte son de son témoignage mais vu que
maintenant c'est en beurre qui a nommé
kate moss balles et les avocats johnny
depp se sont tapé dans les mains et se
et se félicite parce que kate moss du
coût sera interrogé à la barre elle se
pratique aux meilleurs éléments
évidemment on va la suivre le procès
s'est encore qu'un jour je crois bien
terminé